And combined with
that resurgence of the national party's
involvement in community politics
and the involvement of developers in them
and there were a couple of very
controversial environmental issues
that were occurring.
One was where the name was going to get
a centralised sewerage scheme the name
and village and the other was the issue
of waste disposal as we had a landfill.
That was practically full. I think those.
Those issues especially the surge issue
really polarized a village there were those
people who wanted it and saw
it as the only solution
and then there were the
other people who felt
that we really had moved past the point
of putting effluent discharge into creeks
which is what was proposed for name and
that we really needed to find
other malton solutions and
that this was what niman was on about
and in fact it really brought the whole
sort of alternative lifestyle debate if you
like to head that if anywhere.
If there was going to be anywhere in
australia where you would see creative
solutions to sewage disposal then
you would expect to see it in niman
and not expect to see the traditional
centralised treatment works with their
courant pouring into waterways.
The sir it's issue has now been resolved
and women's currently seeing a centralised
surge treatment works being installed
and pipes being laid throughout village
but i think the process of coming
to this point has been one
that has been incredibly divisive perhaps
one of the most controversial issues
that the villagers had to deal
with for a very long time.
It's an incredibly heated
debate. It's seen. Divorce.
Since occur in the community
that probably never you know
didn't exist before i believe
that we got to a point where people
were learning to live together.
You know quite comfortably and each
had respect for the other's position
and points of view
but the the serious debate brought up a
whole lot of sort of underlying prejudice
and it was particularly strong i think
because it focused on environmental issues
and people who've moved to nim
and over the last 20 years have always
been very strong on environmental issues
it's something that they felt
you know passionately about
and while i'm not saying
that the people who lived here before
don't feel the same sort of passions in
relation to the environment i think
that we perhaps have different
solutions to the problems or perceive
that there are different solutions and
the sewerage the sewage treatment works.
You know really brought that
to a head and it's still.
A smoldering issue even though it's
been resolved as far as council
and people in the village are concerned
and i think we'll see the effects of
that actually in the name
and village for you know
quite a time to come.
I think it's been a it's been a major
disappointment for people who were looking
for alternative solutions
for niman i think.
Niman was in the position of finding it
difficult to find alternative solutions
however there were alternative solutions
that could have been considered
the issue though was much more
that the state government weren't prepared
to provide a subsidy for any scheme
that wasn't a centralised scheme.
In addition there were a
whole lot of problems right.
I used around the issues that.
Well if we gave everybody their
own system in their own backyard.
Who would own the system
council would be paying for it
and therefore would own it but in
fact it would be on private property.
So there were these two issues that
weren't resolved and i feel in part
that the the state government
and local governments.
If they've taken a more positive
attitude to onsite sewage disposal
and said how can we do it rather than taken
the attitude well it's going to be very
difficult not really possible
that we would have had probably
a very different outcome.
So it was disappointing for me because i'd
been involved in the debate for you know
two years
and it was disappointing for a lot
of people who weren't involved in it
but who just saw the outcome and i think
it's it's that there's a lesson for nim
and it really in that you
can't afford to stand back
and wait till decisions are made
you really have to be in there
and be involved in the process of making
decisions to have your voice heard.
I believe that if we'd had more
import from people in the village
and there'd been more outspoken
on the issue at the time
and it was to be being debated in
council with the state government
that we would possibly have got a
different outcome for the village.
I would like to say though
that i believe that
that struggle in niman will actually have
impact on other small rural villages
in that i think
that we did a lot to inform the
debate on on sites who is disposal
and i don't believe
that other other villages looking at what
they can do about sewerage will have to
go through the same things that we did
and i think that the state government
and council will be a lot more open on site
effluent disposal for other areas much
more open than they were for nim
and so we've had to cater to local government
we've educated the state government
and fought. When
that lay not in time to have a
different solution for niman.
I often hear it said in council by
counseled women and council staff
that nim and the very divided community.
I actually don't see it as such a divided
community i think it's a very diverse
community it's certainly a very complex
community to have to communicate with
as an alderman and to try and get a
feel of what the community really wants
or you know what they think
they really want. It's.
It's a very difficult community to try
and gauge the feelings of those people
who aren't involved in community
organizations we have quite a
few community organizations in
and the composition of those organizations
are primarily you know people who've
lived here for a long time who've been
part of sort of traditional settlement of
niman and people who've moved into the
area for the purpose of developing land.
So it's extremely difficult for me to
find any forum whereby i can gauge the
opinion of people who've settled here
since aquarius so in the last 20 years.
The only way i can find
out how those people feel
and i mean they're not united on any issue
but just to get a general feeling is
to actually go out into the community
and talk to those people or to find people
that i would can be considered to be
some of the key people in the community.
Who've you know got good networks
and asked them how they
think on particular issues.
Unfortunately i think four niman
and four people have settled here in the
last you know 20 years post aquarius.
They're generally those people are not
involved in community organizations
but i think in part. They've
come here thinking that.
You know they can get away from politics
that they don't want to be any part of
that that therefore they don't
want to be part of a community.
You know community groups or community
organization no matter in what form
or shape and i think that's
you know it's to a detriment.
In some ways because the political process
is work very much through representation
to say local government or state
government or you know to whatever thing
and i think
that whilst we have people who are making
representations to those organizations
supposedly on the part of him
and then representing them
and if the other people don't
get their viewpoint put across
and aren't represented.
Then i think you know they're
generally not happy with the outcomes
and don't get the benefit from
that process that they could.
I'm not saying that i think
that anyone who's you know not involved
in politics is doing the wrong thing
and i recognize that you know sort of
political involvement and activity.
You know doesn't suit
most people but i think
that there are other ways in which people
can have their voice heard in you know
just going and talking to people or
writing letters or somehow you know not.
Not just sort of sitting back in the hills
and letting it all happen around them
or sitting at that in their house in
the village but somehow getting out
and at least talking to people just
that very active talking to other people
about how you feel about things has you
know impact on the outcome
for the community
and it might be only a tiny
little thing but you know.
Millions of grains of sand make up a beat
and you know they all have a part to play.
So i'd like to sort of hope
that you know over the next five to 10 years
we'll see more involvement from people
who you know traditionally traditionally
haven't been part of community politics
because if we don't i think we'll
see niman very much influenced by
perhaps the more you know
conservative backlash
and also by the interest of developers.
Time.
I think
that in the early days it was it was a lot
easier for people to come here to just
buy their piece of land in the hills just
go into the hills live into the here live
in the hills and just come into
nim and to do their shopping
or go to listen more to do their shopping.
It was much easier to live
that sort of lifestyle.
Now i think the reality is
that the hills have become you know sort
of more developed there's more people it's
much harder to be isolated
as it was in those days
and i think there's also the reality that
that sort of lifestyle is very difficult.
It's we all came here with our
ideals that have been sort of shaped
and whittled away
and changed by the reality of living in you
know this sort of lifestyle under these
types of conditions and it's it's
hard. Now for people to sort of.
Sort of sit back
and just watch what happens around them
because they're going to be affected by it.
What was the question you asked. You.
I think the key thing at stake now
is that niman is in the process of.
Undergoing more change than it's
undergone since aquarius 20 years ago.
I mean that that event had a
great impact on the village
and obviously the village
changed direction then
and i think now the villages at the
point of changing direction again
and those people have moved
here over the last 20 years
and say in the first 10
years from aquarius.
If they want to see nim
and retain the things
that are important to them they're
going to have to be part of
that process of having a say
and putting for putting forward the
things that they want to retain
and emphasising you know the positive
aspects of those sorts of things which are
primarily the reasons why we've all moved
to you know the greater emphasis on
self-sustainability the
less consumerist lifestyle.
Not being stuck in the 95 five day a
week work routine doesn't mean to say
that we work any less
hard than anyone else
but you know we're doing it for ourselves.
If people want to retain the things
that are of importance to them then
they're going to have to be a part of the
process of change in a positive way.
Otherwise i believe they're not going
to be happy with the outcomes.
Much.
Time.
Or.
I think things have come to a head in them
and over the past few years
for several reasons.
Primarily i believe
that people from outside have seen
the possibility of selling them
and selling them and to the the broader
community and i think you know it's.
It's very real
and it's definitely there as a potential
i think the challenge for nim
and people who live in niman is
to try and influence that process
and to have some say in the outcome for
instance i believe that it's inevitable
that somebody is going to start
promoting nimbin more strongly as a
a tourist destination or a tourist venue
and i am excited by the idea
that the community itself could
decide what shape and form they want
that tourist development to take
and i believe that if we don't do
that then people from outside
will come in and do it.
Which isn't necessarily a
problem except for i believe
that they won't be promoting what it.
The things
that are important to us the integrity
of niman because they don't know it.
I think the other things are
that the population of niman is about
to grow as the village area has been
increased dramatically over the last year
and we're now likely to see the
population in the village.
Because i think the other thing that's
going to have an influence on niman is
that the actual area of the village has
changed dramatically over the past year
through landry zoning
and we're now likely to see the population
of the village grow from three hundred
fifty to a thousand people which is going
to put an incredible strain on the
village resources
but will also sort of bring a lot more
people into the area were also in the
process of seeing the land surrounding the
village rezoning to rural residential
and once again that's going to
increase the population dramatically.
So there's these sort of competing interests
there's the population of the village
increasing dramatically in surrounding.
Areas there's increase
it of tourist potential
and people wanting to capitalize
on that and there's no way
that niman in its current shape and form.
Can you know can cope with
that animal's going to have to
change to be able to cope with it.
Otherwise you know we're
all going to think
and i mean that's that's
not going to happen.
So i think there's a great opportunity
for us to sort of shape our own future.
And my word of warning would be
that if if we done other
people will do it for us
and we won't like what we get.
So.
Niman gets a lot of publicity. Some of
it's positive. A lot of it is negative.
I think if you look at the name of nim
and further afield you know it's almost
synonymous with the name of you know the
word drugs. I think that's that's very
unfortunate it's very small part of nim
and life it happens to be focused on the
main street which is probably why it
achieves a great deal of attention.
I have seen quite a lot of.
You know positive nim and coverage
by the media and i believe
that there is that a perception
in the wider community.
You know throughout australia
and across the world that nim
and represents a different way of
living and alternative lifestyles.
If you like but it's a choice that.
Challenges and confronts
the dominant paradigm.
And now i can't even remember
what i'm talking about.
So i think that.
Nim and certainly sick of being portrayed.
There's the drug capital of australia
and i think it's a very
unfair label to pin on women
and there are many of us in the community
who work very hard to promote the
positive images of niman and. I
mean there's a multitude of them.
It's not hard to find you know so many
sort of positive things about the nym
and lifestyle.
I think it's been damaging
to us as a community the way
that we've been portrayed in it in the media
i think it's very common for us to see
journalists come in from
outside do a story on nim and
when they really only get a very superficial
insight into the lifestyles of people
hear the name and village the complexity
of the issues that you know exist here
and then go away and write a story that
then you know on top of that gets edited
and we get portrayed in a fairly superficial
way i've seen some very good media
reports on women.
I'd have to say and those sorts of things
that i think we should be you
know we should be encouraging.
I think it really also is up to the
community to take the initiative to promote
itself positively further afield.
You know throughout australia not for
the purposes of bringing tourists here
although it's an inevitable consequence
of it but more because i believe
that nym and have something to
offer to the rest of australia.
You know to the rest of the world
really i mean we're not unique
but you know it's just something
that's happening here and i believe
that people elsewhere
would be interested in it
and in fact i can remember there was
a program on the a b c about us.
Two years ago on couch
and the feedback from
australia was phenomenal.
You know it was people really wanting to
hear more about what we're on about the
things that are important.
And to us how we live our lives just really
sort of basic fundamental things about
how do we. This and you know those
things are exciting those are the things
that i would really like to share and
that i'm sure other people in
yemen are quite open to sharing.
You know those sorts of
those sorts of values
but i think we're pretty sick
of being in the media spotlight
when we just get portrayed in a fairly
negative representative unrealistic way.
I think the acquiring aquarian ideals
have had to be modified substantially the
people who sort of came here with
the vision of living in the hills
and dropping out and creating
their own sort of life and values
and being self-sustainable
have had to realize
that that's just a very difficult path
and in fact it's not possible to cut
yourself off from the rest of the rest of
society and that no matter how we like it
you know it. It follows this everywhere.
I think a lot of what.
Aquarius was the aquarius festival
and its values a lot of those values
are still are still relevant today
that we've been at the forefront of.
A lot of change in australia
and primarily you know environmental issues
come to mind as perhaps being you know
some of the most important things
that are left sort of consumer oriented
lifestyle which was you know very much part
of the aquarius aquarius vision more
self-sustainability more reliance on
you know ourselves as individuals rather
than looking at looking to governments
and the powers that be to
provide for our needs and.
I think we have been able to sort of
demonstrate that it is possible to do
that around here not just around here
but in other parts of australia
obviously those things are happening.
I think too
that it's given us an opportunity to enable
us to provide a more sort of extended
family to build on a
greater sense of community
and that's very much part of you know
european asian and aboriginal lifestyles
but it hasn't been part of you know sort
of white anglo lifestyles i mean most
people grow up leave home and see their
families that easter or christmas.
Whereas here i believe a
lot of people live with
that with support from other people does a
much sort of stronger community emphasis
and community base and the one thing
that is really important to
me about niman is that i know
that you know if anything happens there
are people here who will look after me
and their people i know
they're my friends and
that if anything if my daughters
walking up and down the street.
I know
that there are people on the street who
are going to look after it's it's a very
safe place to live
and you know it's a generally not a violent
place it's a very sort of peaceful
place. I mean we might get sort of
vocal a loud with each other but
and there might be a lot of sort of you
know sort of hidden violence sort of
domestic violence and stuff
but i'm talking about generally women
particularly feel safe in them
and it's a fairly you know
it's a safe place to be
and i think the aquarian vision
was certainly to create a safe.
You know sort of happy
lifestyle for people.
It's a very sound very trite actually and.
Well take out the happy. It
is a safe place. Definitely.
Work. I think also part
of the equerry invasion.
With that people would be empowered
to provide their own housing
and that's been an area which i think
it's been incredibly successful.
There are a lot of owner builders around
here who've been able to build their
houses without borrowing money
and you know i'd like to stress
that if you live on a multiple occupancy
can't borrow money because you don't
actually own anything.
And that's been a really a powerful
thing because when you've got a home
and you've got some security
neighbours you to move forward in life
and you're not stuck into
paying off a mortgage.
You've got a lot more
options with your life.
I think another area that's been really
positive is the concept of shared land
ownership. There are a lot of
people who would really recoil from
that to the idea of owning
land with other people.
Is something that's particularly
pleasant to them but i think in them
and we've demonstrated that groups
of people can come together
and can own things together and
that it can have really positive effects
through just sharing of knowledge
and skills.
So the sharing of resources through
the social support network that
that office has a multitude of benefits
and i'm i'm really proud to be part
of you know a movement that's set
that as an example for
the rest of australia
and i guess i'd equate it with living in
group housing in sydney where you share a
house with a group of people
and i mean anyone who's lived in sydney
in a group house knows that potentially
that can be a very difficult situation
and in sydney the opportunity exists where
where if you're not happy in one group
house you can move into
another group house.
You know it keeps your rents down
and there's more options up
here it's not like that.
If you buy a share in a multiple occupancy
it's extremely difficult to move from
one to the other.
So we're in a position of really
having to work on those differences
that arise personal do.
Princes and learning to sort
of respect personal difference
and to respect other people's values
and i think that's been a really valuable
thing about you know sort of from the
equestrian vision and i think we've
learnt a lot about communication.
We've learnt a lot about
conflict resolution.
We've learnt a lot about just
developing our own personal skills
and those are sort of benefits
that you know the rest of the rest
of the community benefits from
when we then take those
into a community arena
and i mean community in the broader sense
not a multiple occupancy community.
I think the benefits for for
children of this sort of lifestyle.
Tremendous i mean firstly they get
to live in a rural area and i think
that has a lot of a lot
of benefits for children.
They've got space they've got
a beautiful environment.
I think also the fact that they do
they are part of an extended family
and extended social network is
also of incredible importance
and i'd have to say on a personal
level as a single parent.
It's been invaluable to me.
The support that i've been given not
only by my community and the people
that i live with but also by
people within the name and area.
Generally i think also there are
lots of things being offered here
to children that perhaps don't exist
in say you know in city areas.
So they're learning some
really valuable skills
and i my own daughter already helps me
with building you know she'll pick up a
hammer. I never picked up a hammer
into line moved here at the age of 30
or whatever it was and.
Just having a very a very.
Call a life which most children
who live in rural areas have
but in a notional together.
That we're stuck.
I think another benefit for tilden
is just the range of schooling
and educational options that
are available to them here.
I think in the niman area we have six
or seven different schools with
different educational philosophies
and parents are able
to choose to a degree.
You know which school they
send their children to
that will most suit the
needs of their children.
I can't think of you know
many other places where
that sort of range of options
would exist in a rural area.
I think i'd have to say
that my concern in relation to young people
living in this type of environment is
when they reach teenage years. It's
very often that those at those.
It's very often that that
at that age in your life.
The most important thing for you is to
be with your peers and i can remember
that myself
and although i lived in a in a rural area
it was only two miles for me to get into
town and i could walk it whereas
for many people around them
and they live a lot further
out of town than that
and it's much harder for teenagers to be
able to get into town to spend the night
in town or the evening in town and
then to be able to get safely home.
I think
that communities really still need to do
a lot of work on what they offer their
teenage use and it excites me to see a
community like timetable falls community.
You know one of our most established
communities actually putting a great deal of
time and effort and resources into
looking after their teenagers
and trying to give teenagers options
within their own community that mean
that they can stay there for a community
like my own where we have a much smaller
population.
There's a lot more pressure on us to get
our children into town to sort of be.
Part of what's happening there and
then to be able to get them out again.
So it is a challenge for us and
it's one that i don't feel
that we have we have adequately addressed.
I think the other problem
for us is the fact
that we do have a drug scene that's
so concentrated on the main street
and it is a scene that's very
attractive to you know teenage.
Youth when they're going through
that sort of rebelling against everything
cutting ties with the family and stuff
and that's a concern to me.
I think it's really important that
we offer our children a say street
and i believe
that whilst in lots of ways it is a
very safe place to be the drug scene is
something that we haven't
really come to terms with and
that it does have this sort of
almost fatal attraction to teenagers
and some of them will get sucked in
and you know most of them don't.
But some of them will and somehow we
have to look at that as a community
and i think it's probably one of the
most difficult problems that we face
and yet one of the most important
because it's the thing
that most directly affects
our own children's lives.
It really concerns me that
a lot of our teenage youth
that surely end up leaving them
then and i'd like to think
that we had more to offer in terms
of job opportunities people
creating their own employment.
I i believe that you know i
mean teenagers generally leave
and want to go somewhere else
and it's heartening for me to see
you know some of those teenagers
that surely return to nim and after
they've been away for a while
and.